[Music]
you may have heard that there are five
giant garbage patches on earth they're
swirling with vasuda
like bottles small crates nets and many
tiny specks of plastic but while these
massive collections of trash in the
middle of the open ocean get most of the
attention there is another problem and
that one is largely invisible and has
spread to basically every corner of the
planet they're called microplastics and
scientists are still working out what
their repercussions might be but they
say marine debris is one of the most
concerning environmental problems we've
got i'll explain let's go back to the
garbage patches there are five of them
scattered across the world in very
specific locations
like this one here in the indian ocean
or over here in the north atlantic
the most famous is the great pacific
garbage patch it covers an area of 1.6
million square kilometers between hawaii
and california that's roughly three
times the size of france or twice the
size of texas but unlike texas or france
you can't see a garbage patch from space
that's because it does accumulate in the
areas but you know it's just not the
island of trash we've heard about that's
nancy the director of noaa's marine
debris program i called her up to learn
more about how garbage patches form and
how marine debris affects our planet the
patches are more like a really thin soup
you could be sailing through this area
on a boat and not even know you're in it
that invisibility is why trash in the
ocean is such a big issue scientists say
the smaller the plastic gets the more of
a widespread problem it becomes there
are several reasons for that size
matters the big stuff like plastic
bottles crates and fishing nets that are
bobbing around in the garbage patches
are relatively easy to spot and scoop
out of the ocean but the smaller a piece
of plastic is the harder it is to find
and collect and they can't be easily
caught with trolls like the ones you may
have heard about recently sweeping
through the great pacific garbage patch
what begins as one item of plastic trash
can turn into many microplastic pieces
larger items can get broken down by the
wind sunlight and even the ocean's
vibrant life forms
some of these microplastics are as small
as a grain of rice or a strand of hair
environmental scientists say they've
found microplastics in even the most
remote places on the planet it's an
arctic ice it's on the seafloor it's on
our beaches it's really everywhere we
look it is ubiquitous even though
scientists know that microplastics are
virtually everywhere they don't know
exactly where they're the most
concentrated if you don't know where the
plastic is we also don't know where the
harm that plastic is doing eric is an
oceanographer at utrecht university in
the netherlands i called them up to
learn more about where the plastic might
be found his lab builds machine learning
models of how trash moves across the
oceans one of the reasons that
environmental scientists focus on
garbage patches is that they're the most
visible sliver of the ocean's trash
universe but if you think about the harm
that the plastic can potentially have on
marine life then it's not so much about
how many kilos of plastic there are it's
about how many items of plastic there
are there are many more organisms that
can eat a tiny piece of plastic than
organisms that can swallow an entire
plastic bag or so eric told me that the
hope is that the models his lab is
building will help scientists develop
better cleanup plans to target the most
vulnerable ecosystems
another problem because they're so hard
to clean up the microplastics that do
end up in the ocean could stick around
for decades if not longer potentially
causing long-term harm we started using
plastics in the 1950s so we don't yet
know how long plastics take to
completely degrade so then what happens
to that tiny piece of plastic is it
could be ingested by fish it could be
ingested by a bird as it's flying by or
it could just continue to stay there the
direct long-term effects of
microplastics on more complex animals
like birds and humans are still being
worked out according to researchers
studying how tiny specks of plastic may
affect human cells has been difficult
scientists have found turtles with
dozens of microplastics in their guts
which they say may potentially affect
their survival because the animals end
up eating plastic rather than real food
some data suggests that microplastics
can shorten the lifespans of marine
microorganisms like zooplankton
they can also affect how well they
reproduce these effects could have
outsized repercussions because these
tiny creatures make up the bases of the
food chain that can even impact us
microplastics can move from one part of
our planet to others it's all connected
by some estimates people may ingest
hundreds of microplastics daily through
the air we breathe and the salt and
water we consume but if you really look
into where the highest concentration of
plastic is it's close to coastlines it's
much closer to
where people live and where the rivers
actually put the plastic into the ocean
it's super local and we now know many
many hot spots around cities where
plastic concentrations are hundreds of
times larger than in the open ocean
garbage patch the fact that the highest
concentrations of plastic or closer to
the coastlines may be depressing but it
also means we can do something about the
more than eight million metric tons that
end up in the ocean each year according
to the researchers who came up with that
estimate that's the equivalent of
finding five grocery bags full of
plastic on every foot of coastline in
the 192 countries they studied by far
the best thing that you can do is
actually start cleaning up beaches eric
says that it's on beaches that much of
the plastic tends to go from big to
micro through rubbing on the sand and
rocks eric and nancy also told me that
limiting the amount of disposable items
we use and disposing of them correctly
could also help protect our oceans and
all the creatures that live in them
if you want to catch more videos like
this please don't forget to hit
subscribe and for more of our
environmental coverage i've left some
links down below especially thanks for
watching and gracias